council meeting
um we're not expecting any
fire drills tonight but uh in the event
that the alarm does go off please follow
the directions
that the staff will
give
excuse me speak up a bit is it
[Music]
um welcome to uh any of those members of
the public that are watching us tonight
on youtube
so we've got any apologies for items
that's not on one
of them
item two on the agenda is the uh minutes
of the 20th of september um council
meeting on the extraordinary meeting
heaven on the 5th of october so i'll
take the 20th of september
first of all
and i'll just run through them um
page at a time
so the first page five
six
seven
sure
[Music]
i did apologize for not attending but i
did pre-empt by sending my
okay so you wish that to be circulated
that's why i would like to keep it happy
because if people remember you noted
them
but you don't have a record of them then
i would like that we
have a record that could be at uh
[Music]
um at the bottom the last paragraph that
said
the finance manager buys foreign
i'll share the um
slides and the actual presentation of
the video
before
all those possible investments and
products about eight to nine of the
slides which i think
thank you moving on page nine
page ten
11
and 12.
someone had to move those ministers take
some music secondly
that's what's in all in favor of bishop
[Music]
[Music]
again i'll run through them
this is
number 13 at the bottom so page 13
[Music]
14
and
15.
no questions i'll ask for a proposal
please
on secondary
[Music]
and all thanks appreciate
okay and again
if there is any against
abstentions
[Music]
thank you
okay item three on the agenda is uh
public contributions i understand we
have uh one speaker
um i forgot to come forward we'll be
here
[Music]
[Music]
um
on this inaugural day of the un
conference cop 26 i'm addressing you
with the aim of persuading torridge
district council to support the climate
and ecological emergency bill
the support of councils will hopefully
pressure many more mps to support the
bill which would replace the 2008
climate change act
which all also began life as a private
members bill but which is now out of
date
the bill has been drafted by caroline
lucas of the green party with a team of
scientists academics lawyers and
campaigners guided by the current
science calling for vital and urgent
action to tackle the climate and
ecological emergency faced by humanity
the government has its own environment
bill which it states makes the cee bill
unnecessary
the environment bill has supported
environmentalists scientists and there
are overlaps but there are big
differences which is why the cee bill
needs your support
my aim this evening is to draw your
attention to these differences
the government's environment bill
requires the legislation to halt the
decline in species abundance in the uk
but the cee bill would oblige the
government to reverse that decline so
that we would actually see nature on the
road to recovery by 2030.
they there have been amendments to the
environment bill but
the issues of emissions from fossil
fuels aviation and shipping are still
not there
nor are meat
peat or diet
forests still appear only in relation to
commercial logging
all of these areas are covered by the
cee bill
on targets the environment bill is vague
and limited
the secretary of state would have to set
a minimum of one target in each area
there is no requirement as to how
ambitious the targets are or what
exactly they cover
the cee bill would set annual interim
targets which must be projected to have
a net positive impact on young people
local communities and the vulnerable
it would also include financial support
and retraining for those whose
livelihoods are affected by
transitioning out of polluting
industries
the environment bill fails to address
the global dimension of the crisis in
our environment whereas the ce bill
recognizes the interconnectedness of
systems globally
it asserts that the act will halt and
reverse the loss of nature caused by the
uk and other countries activities
historically
and it is notable that in his speech
opening cop this morning boris johnson
also acknowledged the necessity of
seeing the climate crisis as an
international and interconnected one
have you got much more mr slaughter
because your three minutes is nearly up
but if you've only got a minute or two
i'll extend one minute yes unless that
our final point on citizens assemblies
which the ce bill calls for is part of
the decision making process
um to recommend measures to be included
in the government strategy if and when
the bill is passed
these measures do not have to be adopted
by the secretary of state as certain mps
have asserted wrongly over and over
again but they must be considered by
that secretary of state therefore
citizens assemblies do not replace
established democratic press processes
but aim to involve the public more
democratically
our prime minister has called the cop 26
conference a last chance for humanity to
mitigate the except the effect of the
climate emergency
please councillors be on the right side
of history in the decision you make
tonight
thank you thank you
okay it counts as item four on your
agenda's declarations of interest you
all know the score uh if there is an
item that needs declaring i don't need
to take the time please state the
interest okay
item five is to bring the
agenda between items part one and two
well there are no part two items this
evening
so item six is to consider
correspondence or the business brought
forward by the direction of the chair
i've only got one matter um i had an
email around five o'clock this afternoon
from cancer just
reminding counselors that if they could
wear a mask um when they're moving
around uh between any meetings in
particular when we've got the planning
on thursday and friday which is spread
over two days so just be mindful of that
item seven to answer questions submitted
under procedure rule a9 we have two
questions so they did the first one
one it's from actually
the second from council
would you like to
would you like to speak on yours or
yeah
[Music]
and
um
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
the mask off just so i can speak
unfortunately i apologize in front of me
but i did test negative on their natural
field test at four o'clock this
afternoon so i have taken extra
proportion before coming to meeting
tonight thank you
i thank joe wells and all the work of
the benefits team in torres because they
i've got a really difficult year with
all things that meant all the parallel
and understanding and how they cope with
things like uh universal credits and all
the rest of it i congratulate them and
thank them for all the work they do
within porridge
i'm really interested in the answer i
noticed that um in the first one they
say 5038 universal credits so six
million uh nationwide in last week's
budget on wednesday from ritchie sunette
and cena's turret is all totals of the
size of the united kingdom population
that's interested in that we've got one
of the national situations so it's
interesting to come through that way
and rather delay too long um
i picked up the juicer for injury
foundation research which always
interests me
um on the situation and they did comment
that there was a good budget for those
in work
because the paper relief which is almost
like the income tax that people of the
weekends pay when their incomes begin to
rise and they're already paying 55 pence
in the pound which i think is quite
interesting because um even the highest
paid in the countries that will be on 50
percent in the towing maybe 45 actually
but there you go but it's thank richie
for that and also the minimum wage went
up from 890 i think the 960 so the guys
can do the extra work to get the money
they're going to lose from the top up
but the people that are going to really
lose and it ties in to knowledge of
motion that counselor girls will mistake
later on
is the people that really lose out there
are those that cannot work
and there's two groups i would
particularly those who have life limited
conditions who are facing illness they
can't work and work those extra hours to
gain that 20 pound they're now losing
and they don't get the chance to earn
the money through the top-up that may
have come back from that point of view
and i also have come across a group of
people who are caring for their elderly
parents
um because there's no longer the social
care available that has been in the past
people have double job now if they're
working within the care industry and
there are now real shortages in
providing care for those in need there's
a whole group of people who are in their
sort of 50s and 60s caring for their
elderly parents having to give at work
and having no money at all coming in at
the moment so what i would like to say
is when it comes to removing the juicer
from wrong tree foundation they just
talk about among the people in our
society who cannot work or when they say
cancer patients
and i did work with them i'd be clear
interested because i linked them to ca
being still at the present moment but i
would like to not just say cancer
patients but people with life limited
conditions
and with disability those care for young
children and elderly parents that's what
my name that's a very long question
that's right guys a very long question
but all i'm saying is i hope there's a
council we direct people to the citizens
advice bureau um we have christians
against poverty i think in boston
so we have the tpbs i think this is
benefit work um you might use this
situation i hope we have no money left
in our council that's production scheme
at the end of the year for working age
clients they still have to put 25
percent
of towards their council tax um to pay
for torridge and i just hope there is a
coastal tax reduction scheme we make
sure that we support them as best we can
thank you for listening to me chair
thank you thank you
item eight on the agenda is uh
a devon and cornwall police update and
i'd like to introduce um superintendent
toby davis um to come up and give his
report
i'll put the table yeah
[Music]
hi can you hear me
hi hello everybody uh i i know that i
know some of you i think um but there
are some new faces because in the last
18 months the opportunity to come here
is perhaps being um
hasn't happened quite as much as i would
like uh and you're on zoom which doesn't
work very well with the police systems
as well which is made a lot more
difficult but those who don't know me
toby davies i'm the local pleasing area
commander for north and west end so to
have a stock
right up through to
the edge of linton and we're broken into
uh four different sectors so your
torridge obviously within
the whole district area i've got west
evan
and we've also got north denver district
has broken into barnstable and north
devon sector and of course i brought you
in along today inspect you and see it
because you and is your inspector for
your sector for the for the whole area
so we've replaced those that remember
sean connelly who's now welcome okay so
history but we are um
we're made up of numerous teams i'm not
enough time to go through all of the
difference that's that but you know most
of the councillors i know you'll know
we've got our response officers we've
got the neighbourhood officers our pcsos
and we've got the investigators
generally our detectives who are uh who
are up here as well but there's lots of
other teams behind that as well
intelligence officers armed officers dog
units public protection child abuse uh
domestic abuse officers there's loads of
stuff and if any of you
want to understand more about what we do
because it is sometimes lifting back the
curtain and understanding there's so
much other stuff that's going on
have a chat with you and have a chat
with a local team and we can perhaps
bring you out and you can come and look
to see what goes on
um
in your in your area so
i would if i had time i would spend some
time going back over the last 18 months
and i would talk about the uniqueness
the challenge we've been through the
kovic the g7 the summer that's just come
off the back of that
uh as well i don't think that would be
great use of the time it's then i'd far
rather look
forwards about some of the stuff we're
going to be doing so i'll do a little
bit on that
there is still within the system and
urine is working with the team really
hard because we've got a bit of a
backlog on the back end of all of that
we've got pent up demand so there's lots
of inquiries and work we're still doing
that's kind of linked to all of that
demand that we've had over the last few
months but bear with us as we we're
catching up on that the good news is
most of you have seen in the media the
talk about the uplift in policing
that boris committed to about 18 months
two years ago the 20 000 offices
that has slowly
uh has been falling down into our area
and a good example is up until christmas
um we've now got 16 new offices we'll be
starting here over the next six seven
weeks
and that's student officers and some of
those are transferees that are
transferring other parts of the country
to come to come down here and work
we we've already and this has been a
commitment are going to increase the
neighborhood officer strength by one
neighbor beat manager to every sector so
there'll be one extra navy officer
coming to this sector and the other
officers will then will go into our
response and our investigation team so
before i just talk about some more areas
we're going to focus on i'll give you a
really quick snapshot about how things
are going and it's difficult to compare
because you can't really compare the
last two years the lockdowns has changed
the whole dynamic of policing so we've
gone back to 2019 to make some of our
comparisons
calls the last 12 months up
significantly so lots more calls come
into place
the good news is is that crime over that
period has fallen
by uh by 10
which is quite significant and it bucks
a trend it's it's a higher fall than
other parts of the force in the country
if you look at beheaded population
for this area and there might be some
recent media sensationalist reports that
have been stuck on some of our local
sites the reality is the header
population
and devon cornwall is the safest force
in the country
this is the safest area within devon
cornwall so you can't get much better
than that uh in honesty not saying we
haven't got our issues there are issues
but the reality is as an area we are as
safe as it gets
in terms of the stuff that we're really
proud of is when it comes to that crime
is actually are we catching
are we catching those responsible are we
getting the person and getting the top
of the victim
and we much like you do as counsellors
up here punch way above our weight the
reality is we have one of the best
outcomes in terms of catching people for
what they're doing in uh in the region
not just within the force and when it
comes to our priority crimes which is
domestic abuse we're seen as an outlier
we have a we have an outcome rate which
is far higher than any other parts of
the region and a lot of that i'm not
taking the correct that's down to the
likes of yourselves not communities that
work with us and help us
to catch people so there are stuff and
you would may
want to speak to you and there'll be
there's are areas where we are seeing
some increases and there's proactive
elements which you can see is a positive
um domestic abuse
numbers going up since we've gone into
some lockdowns
you could see that at one end i'm
pleased people are willing to report we
can address it at the other end it's not
a good thing obviously but um so the
areas of focus
and i'm saying this as much as the
commander as i'm the community safety
partnership chair from north devon and
torridge as well so sharing kind of the
direction that we're very likely to take
we've got a meeting that's coming
shortly but we try to follow clearly the
priorities set by the chief constable
the police and prime commissioner and
and her plan but equally as a community
partnership what we feel is important
and the uniqueness area so
um and janet if you don't even hear
tonight but janet and dean do a
fantastic job for you here janet
williams and
and dean as you probably know
the one given is serious violence
and violence against women and girls so
i won't spend my time talking about it
but you probably know
the government have made it legislation
it's a duty that we as a local authority
police work together to tackle that it's
not a choice and it's the right thing to
do in any case but we have to work
together with partners
to to address that i would like to
suggest the most likely way a female is
going to come to harm appear is behind
closed doors probably something they
know that's probably a domestic view so
that's an area we're going to put a huge
amount of focus to we've already got sub
groups and loads of work going on there
the other area that is sadly is an area
where there's
significant violence still is around
county lines and drug dangerous drug
networks
we are still
an area that some of the really nasty
franchises drug groups have come out of
the cities they come up here they use
serious violence they use sexual
violence
and they cuckoo addresses are very
vulnerable people to take over the drug
market
um so we've had a huge amount of success
around these and we've and with the
awareness up here is fantastic but it
relies on
the community providing that information
we only are we're fed by that
information that you provide and so as
councillors anything you can do to
encourage people to spot the signs spot
and address strange people appear
addresses or dealing that that becomes
really obvious and overt in your area
make sure people are reporting it we
have to we live off that information
another thing
i sadly would um we're going to have to
rightly raise as a priority i'll make no
apologies for this is road safety
um this patch in particular of the
summer had a particularly tragic period
of three weeks where we've lost a lot of
young life and the reality is is the
most likely way any of us in here are
going to lose a loved one is not going
to be through crime it's going to be on
the road
and so we're going to put a huge amount
of emphasis as a partnership and as the
police around road safety so there's
been a number of campaigns already
and the social media has really pushed
the fact that we're out there doing a
lot of activity on the road and that
does work it gets mixed reports back as
you can expect
but the other area is we have our
specialist road policing teams and a
team called the no excuses team which
are already a bit sneaky beaky and
playing
in plane cars they have been up here for
significant periods of time targeting um
this particular area and on one
particular day with an over four hour
period 64 tickets
uh and it's not tourists and if
everyone's gonna try and say and blame
others it's locals i know it's not
pretend it is it's often 90 percent it's
people here who know the roads um sadly
the other thing i was going to really
push is operation snap
has anyone heard of operation snap so if
you've got anybody who's got the dash
cams in the vehicle you can upload onto
our website direct any really bad
examples of driving and then it
automatically creates a statement
creates the evidence and we can then
take and progress that
um through court
and this is another one that's very
mixed uh and i i did this in northern
district council i would say haha we're
probably overjoyed and the other half
perhaps we're a little bit more
personally nervous but
we're going to have
those speed detection bands you see on
the a361 they come from distance and
they don't come as much as i'd like
we are
in the next few months we are going to
be getting two speed detection officers
based up in north and west devon
and they're gonna have the two vans up
here which basically means that every
day there will be two vans somewhere on
our patch on the roads
um that will be detecting those that are
traveling at excess speed and i'm
convinced that will start to adapt and
uh some of our driving behaviors but the
big thing for you i know some of you are
really engaged in this already in those
rural communities
is we can't have offices everywhere we
can't be at every spot and we can't beat
every road and there will still be
people who drive like idiots
and community speedwatch is a fantastic
thing
and if any of you have been part of it
and that embarrassment because it tends
to be people that are local
if you get out there um we've now it
hasn't had it has had its issues in
establishing it but the website now
gives details we've got a dedicated
individual leading on it if you if you
have an area and the location can be
assessed it's safe to do so
look to the community feedback so i'd
encourage you and go on our website and
you can see the details
so my very final uh
point
i want to raise is
that an area that i don't want to forget
i know as a partnership we're really
keen on this is and social behavior and
the dangers of course we're going to
concentrate on the hidden harm on that
that vulnerability
but persistent asb has a really big
impact on communities and it actually
has a really big impact on feelings of
safety and how safe people feel in their
community and it's really visible and i
just feel that some of our town centres
probably less so this side maybe more so
um on your colleagues on the district
side in particular
the street attacks the drunkenness the
swearing the stuff it just gives a sense
of not feeling safe even if sometimes it
isn't necessarily um
at the case so
as a community partnership i know janet
and dean are really big on this as well
it's something we really want to focus
on but i make a plea please to use all
the counsellors it's not just about the
police and there's sometimes there's an
emphasis of pushing it back to say it's
a police it's not it's a problem for all
of us it's a societal issue let's be
honest but we all have a part um to play
we're we're quite superficial we can go
in on the surface but the root causes of
a lot of this and social behavior tends
to be something that we all and local
authority health parents schools
licensing we all need to work on and it
can be to designing stuff out lighting
cctv
marshalls all all there's loads of stuff
that we need to get into so i urge us
all
and i know you will and i know here we
will but that we work together to try to
tackle some of those issues i know we
are a big part of play i'm not going to
deny that but i want us all to
to really have a push and there's an
anti-social behavior steering group
which feeds off the back of our
committed partnership
which your district and janet and ossie
and dean sit on
we're going to target really push those
repeat individuals we're going to use
all the tools available to us to to
target those individuals and address
those continuously back poor behaviors
we're going to push some initiatives
over the next few weeks and months
across the two-town centers to try and
sort of retake back some of the
territory if i'm honest in some parts of
the patch
um and you've got some really good stuff
here with
the marshals the wardens and extra
powers that some of your staff are using
as well to tackle uh some of these
issues but my final key to you is
how many times does a counselor come to
me or a business come to me and say
there's massive asb loads of issues
outside my shop
and you go on to the records and we look
at your records or our records and
there's nothing if people don't report
it we can't deal with it there's no
point people coming and moaning about
stuff that they have reported because
how can we have any chance to even
knowing about as a partnership that
there's no report so
encourage people to use the reporting
mechanisms that are out there now i've
talked started on as i always do so i'm
going to stop now and just really
briefly i thought
you were on the bus here but
just uh just like you know this is you
and sia you just introduce yourselves
yeah no only just to say that um nobody
hear me okay yeah yeah um my name's unc
obviously i've been here to replace sean
comedy since since the summer um nice to
actually see some faces because we've
all been so detached
i know the complexity there's so much
better being on screen and so i just
want the opportunity to
say hello so that people could see me in
person
um nearly 20 years in policing i'm on
promotion to inspector three and a half
years in the custody environment but
prior to that i was making the team
leader advanced for sergeant
um for about seven years i think and
then previously response sergeant over
here in biddeford so i know the area
well
and it's my dream job
and
i'm
desperate about that kind of community
dead policing that partnership work
because the police now we can't just
throw resources that's something to a
problem an issue with twenty fixed it
our resources um diversified so many
different areas of harm and
vulnerability
that the only way we can truly solve
issues and problems is to work together
you know we can arrest those kids trying
to certain behavior every day
if we can't get them back into education
if we can't get their families stable
without a nasty domestic violence going
in the background those kids are going
to continue to offend and the boss will
just pick up when he says that asb we
kind of think of major crime and
anti-social behavior down here
you know
kids being abused or misusing you know
class c drugs like dynamics to me is
just as harmful as seasoned
adults feeling heroin because of the
kids or those younger elements of
society we've got that chance today
and we've got more support structures in
place to turn it around so
my focus is really on that youth and
that harm and making sure that we're
very proactive and robust as a police
force but also we'll be pushing on those
other agencies and services to come in
and put that network around those
individuals we can break that cycle
um
i'm very operationally minded i'd much
rather people phone me up talk to me
email me and like the boss said if you
want to come out spend the day
see what it is we do on the ground and
open
[Music]
i've just been massively impressed with
being in the team with janet the joint
work around the public space and
protection order and i think it's
absolute class in fact that everybody's
own responsibility around that
and the improvements are tangible um
so
just to welcome any questions at all or
don't wait for me to just counselor i
think he's got his hand up yeah thank
you thank you uh thank you
yeah just to say that you mentioned
martians around the town and they have
been very very good this summer
in the evening times when they walk
around it's a visual thing i think you
know they see people walking around a
lot of comments on that but the only
thing is now
they've stopped patrolling me in the
evening they only patrol in the daytime
and i i'd like to see them in the
evening and perhaps next year you know
we have a few more because
it seems to me a fairly
um a low-cost thing to do
but i think a lot of people at the time
in front of the brandon
they have made a lot of coverage to say
oh you know we serve these people around
and it does make things a lot easier
yeah the feedback's been fantastic
around the marshals and that's not just
here that's across the patch the reality
is is over the summer that was police
and crime commissioner funded that
specifically uh that funding pot has now
gone
and there was certainly
there was an eagerness to try to
encourage uh councils to perhaps find
ways to to support that continuing
funding if i'm honest i don't know where
the money uh uh
got to i don't know how long that's been
sustainable i do know that you're one of
the areas that carry has tried to look
to carry it on so i'm not everywhere
everywhere has but you've got my
my support unfortunately one thing i
don't have is deep pockets with money
i'm afraid it's uh
thank you for that we've got cancer
forward first man
set cancer forward yeah i'll stand up
we've got the public
probably tuned in
um
great views over time thank you for
coming
i don't want to get too personal
obviously um it's quite common ones i've
got this year i've got an ilp
come to me as well as my concerns so
could i ever if i can answer it today
fine but i want it in writing what is
the status of a police station because
my understanding is if you've got to do
a complaint
and i understand it so 101 would present
the link magazine this week right
or you walk in like i do
or whatever mine without coping because
what i want to be assured in writing
that
everybody is treated on parity nobody's
got any friends or family policies it
can walk in an office create a benefit
could you just clarify that for me if
you can't do it in public
i can guarantee that there will be
parity of service for everybody but you
know and understand i can't talk about
an individual matter here
um so if that specific element i will
talk we can talk offline and we'll talk
about but the um the ways of reporting
to the police go on a website i i know
that there's um there's loads of varying
ways i know lots of feedback but you've
got the 101 but there's there's loads of
the ways which are encouraged to report
the police and it's not about using the
phone there's one on email there's stuff
you can do now into the chat box and
there's loads of other stuff ways we're
trying to encourage people to get in
touch with the police but you can
equally
you can get hold of your neighborhood
team as well there's a direct entry to
your local navy beat team for non-urgent
matters so but i would say just put the
obvious comment if it's an urgent
matter ongoing then it's it's it's not
[Music]
the anti-social behavior issue i've had
a few people come to me uh not majorly
recently but this year and say that a
bit of a toilet specifically
are quite intimidating
and lots of genuinely local people
men actually
really didn't want to use them um
now
in terms of reporting anything there's
nothing specific to report you know what
what would you say i went to the new and
i felt uncomfortable or i didn't go to
the loop because i felt comfortable
that's really a gray area how did we
approach that do you know what i've i've
i've annoyed myself i've missed a really
big
thing that i could have uh sold to as
counsellors
so there is the bit around reporting if
you see stuff couldn't you report it
there's actually a s behavior report it
and it sometimes might be appropriate to
go for local authority because it's
noise it might be through to us however
there's a new thing the government that
created all the homeopathy and some of
you may have heard it called street safe
and that is a um
it's where you can say there are areas
of your patch
that you just don't feel safe you don't
feel safe walking around it might be
lighting it might be perception it might
so that's exactly the kind of place
where you said you know what it's an
area
and it has that feel of not being safe
now the irony is it's probably far safer
than most parts of this country in
london but london has a very they've
done they have a good job of making
things feel a lot safer than that for
the reality and here it could be the
opposite way around so i encourage a
north different district you can all go
online members probably go online
they're they're going to produce a map
which is going to they're going to
highlight parts of our patch and it's
already on there now and then
biddeford's got lots of locations and
i think i think the times haven't been
on there it's been on there but it's
like you say it's very much
the windows are broken on these
buildings the litter has not been
cleaned up and it's so it's that joint
thing yes we can patrol the toilets you
know all day long but actually
if we're not there they can make anybody
more comfortable using them probably not
it's probably lighting
the environment how do we design it out
it's a combination of us a little bit
but also a long-term solution the
toilets have to look nicer it's it's
that kind of holistic view
and i think that's our point the point
would be is that i would like i'm kind
of i know it's going to create us more
uh a challenge but the reality is i
think as local authority and police we
would love to see where are the areas in
our pla and our patch that people don't
feel safe and it's only going to work
actually the community
put that information into that system so
i it was in my notes
i flown through
do um do go out there and share that
it's called street it's street safe it's
a home office initiative
and already the some areas have been
very savvy and they've really pushed
that and it's and i suspect it might
come
it might come with money that's why
that's part of my thinking
[Music]
ultimately you um
mentioned about traffic observation and
parishes doing their own and i'll take
it from the parish council meeting on
friday
and they were very much looking at
community speed watch which is great but
they were told by your chap
focusing on it and that the cost of the
speed cameras was 1200 pounds
and that the villagers had to buy them
themselves
and there hadn't really been any mention
of joined up thinking with the villagers
you know perhaps a few villages could
get together and share
and part of this cynic in me
just thought
well who's making money out of that
camera because you can buy a d5 or rent
one for 1 800 pounds ish
you know
surely
and all the high-vis stuff as well and
i'm just a little bit cynical about the
the money that is available we're all in
the same boat incidentally in the public
sector aren't we we're all strapped for
cash and challenged
but it's easy to
put it on someone else and what you say
about the toilets and yes they need
liquor paint or whatever but actually
the point was there were people
lingering outside which was what made
you know you can accept that public
tweets can be a bit rotty but it was
the
sort of persons that were lingering
outside and what they were up to was
more of the thing
but the point is it's not um vote safety
is not just about the police in fact the
vote for camera partnership is a
partnership of individuals i can't
answer how much money is in the pot how
much money goes out i think they i do
know that there are plenty parts of
devon and cornwall where parishes have
worked together to share that camera um
and i guess that would be if i'm pushed
back that's where i think a counselor
who's got those links those abilities to
go out there and encourage others to
come on board and share that cost
because 200 pounds if it goes on a stage
if you it saves a life
what they're talking about yeah
if your man could promote that you know
as well when he goes out
yeah no i thought i should go back and
see i don't know the detail on the cost
but i'll go back and find out i know i
know the man you're talking about so i
shall i suspect
i think councillor hudgins
wants to speak now and then hopefully
the last one when we cancel another
just talk about the social media side if
i get that um but the biggest questions
sorry
um the biggest complaint is the 101
um and i know what you're saying there's
lots of other ways but we i mean
wholesomely a lot of older people there
they will not will not go online and
don't use social media and there's a lot
of things you've talked about like the
streetwise things like happening i
didn't know about um
maybe that needs to get out to the
public more i'm not quite sure how you
go about that um but definitely the 101
is a major issue um and i think you miss
out you talk about like businesses
shocking problems outside it's not
reported but the reason a lot of it
isn't completely reported is because of
101
no i i i i can't come to a point of
meeting i don't what i want not
mentioned
as you can understand what i'd say is is
that if i haven't got performance fixed
hands it's not my department
um but i know that it's improved
significantly and what i would say is i
get you right there are some people who
still the only way is going to be for
the phone and i get that but what we are
trying to encourage is that those people
who are more savvy around the social
media and other elements use the other
means to report it it gives us more
capacity but this is only my personal
point of view
there's a difficult balance to be struck
because some people want to go to the
one-on-one and get that immediacy of of
service of call
that means more people get behind a
phone line and that's more police
officers off the street i i i'm as a
geographic commander
i'm also the old i'd rather having
people there ready to respond when
there's some questions
so that balance is gonna be struck so
people sometimes want that music phone
service because i want equally to ensure
we've got officers on the ground ready
to respond we're a massively rural area
and so for me to have people that are
out about is
your point of one made i get it but
there is balance we strike we put loads
at the back end
taking the calls but that might mean
less on the street so it's about getting
that right balance but please do
encourage those that can to use the
other means to report stuff because it
is the phone that is predominantly what
people still use and some people could
have done it in a different way
there is also just add community
messaging which you can
sign up for on the website and that can
send you emails text adverts messages
leave your points automatic message on
your landline
that can give people updates on
crimes in your area on scans we can put
messaging out to it
so if we're appealing for witnesses over
minister it's really useful um so i'd
encourage people those sort of isolated
areas if they sign up to that news then
they can get updates about you know
those sort of things which which we've
mentioned today which might not
otherwise get you can't get on the web
or got that more sort of i.t sort of
tilt
yeah thank you council another
thank you chair yeah
i hear what you say about the public
contacting and giving the police
information
well
this summer through the year earlier
this year i had two residents
in my area i'm in northern
and they gathered information about drug
dealing in broad daylight
somebody coming into the car parking up
people coming and meeting with them
they got it they got
registration numbers
even photographs of the cars they
contacted the police
nobody came around so they contacted
again it dragged on and on and on
they had promises made that people who
come around and see these
these two residents and they didn't then
they got in touch with me and i managed
to get things moving
so
generally people feel there's not much
point in reporting anything to the
police because nothing happens and
that's a fact that's how people feel
another one
was
this community speedwatch i'm a member
of northern town council as well as the
district
we've got we've got trained volunteers
and we've got one of our councillors who
wants to run it and he's been there a
merry chance trying to get this thing
off the ground
five of the
volunteers there he's worried they're
gonna say oh forget it or not bobby will
not do it
now he's going on the 8th of november
downtown it's down to plymouth
to meet with the pcc
and uh chief constable
and i think he'll give them both barrels
about how this hasn't been working
we've put forward sites in northern
western or appledore that we'd like to
operate with some we've got one that
they've agreed to do it on but nothing's
happening
so you know
i sit here and i get very angry hearing
you as if everything's
going all right well it's not and the
public out there
know it and and they're losing faith in
the police and that's a shame that
that's happening but it is happening
that people just don't want to contact
at least because they know it's
pointless and and i experienced this
no
i also hate to hear that i think it's a
shame that there are people out there i
mean the facts are that this is safe
area so i get but that doesn't that
doesn't affect there are people out
there who who don't always have that
that confidence i get that so community
speed watch
um you give you examples
uh where they are i know that they're
the the officer who's you i've been
referring to you've been going around
there are a lot of abilities lots of
talent for wonderland first thing is it
has to be safe it would be
self-defeating we put three volunteers
onto a road which puts them at risk so
that they can't and they can't suddenly
immediately click to turn up there and
then sort that speed watch and it does
it involves inertia and some hard work
from that village initially to make that
happen but where it's relevant where
it's going to improve safety
and where it's safe for the volunteers
so it's not simply that the drug dealing
aspect look drug dealing is pervasive
across all society it's across every
market town and we if we like to pretend
that doesn't happen then i think we'd be
pretty naive the reality is it's
pervasive and equally it's incredibly
difficult to prove we do some techniques
we talk about there are other techniques
we don't talk about for obvious reasons
and the fact that somebody may have seen
somebody believing what they believe to
be drug dealing isn't sufficient to then
act and suddenly to bang somebody up and
it is not simple as that it's a huge
amount of work so one catch somebody
with those controlled drugs and show
that they were then they're going to
supply that however
what we do is we prioritize where that
the dealing where there is most
significant harms i said from beginning
the county lines adventure networks
whether it's to kids outside schools and
that information that you've given i
would almost willingly guarantee
that now sits within our intelligence
system and where that's cooperated with
lots of other information that then
helps us in that with that activity so
obvious reasons if we then went out and
shared exactly what we were planning to
do it would become self-defeating
because part of the point of
that activity is is that we want to then
go and do some of that activity through
some of our the other techniques which
we wouldn't be able to share with
sharing the public so i can assure you
our information our activity relies on
and actually up here we're one of the
best parts of the country people talk to
the police so make some exceptions for
the people you're talking to council
leather but actually the reality is
we're pretty good the community here is
really supportive and generally useful
information and we go on and do a lot of
stuff and stuff with it but
at the point way
okay hopefully this is going to be the
last one um can't you afford pizza yeah
just quite brief um
but i can say i mean
thanks for that i do understand a bit
where he's coming from i mean there is
good and bad you know i will take you
crying your back i respect you for that
but what i will say is a bit like an
average store if i might be honest
i'll work i'm gonna make it unbreak but
i'm sure you're not doing that
but just briefly
and it is topical with sadly what's been
happening recently and sadly a lot of
bad press which you would concur you
know which is happening right they were
wrongly
i'm thinking more so now of vulnerable
people and
females would you know
hopefully
promote that any officer on in your pack
should they be questioned about their
identity
they will get treated civilly
and respected because i think i'm ahead
of the game i actually have to do that
on the 30th of march myself xcid block
who helped me out because of the way i
was pretty good so could you actually
confirm that your staff will take it
seriously and be careful as anybody that
challenges the idea of that officer of
course and i do get it the press is is
not being positive on police things
that's horrific instead happened in
in the met um you know it's just that
that every officer is disgusted and
shamed that somebody would
wearing our badge in uniform we'll go
and do that it's disgusting uh what i
would say is there's lots of advice on
the net it is difficult i do get it and
then and lone female being stopped but
there is asked to to hear the radio
ask for other colleagues to be around
love it there's a lot there is lots of
stuff but i get i do get that um so it's
um but
yeah
well thank you very much uh
intended navies and inspectors here i
think that's probably one of the best
police updates that's been my privilege
to sit in on for quite some time so
thank you very much for seeing me thank
you
you can be dismissed no problem
match the rubric tonight
okay right we'll now move on to item 9
on the agenda which is the housing
provision
options report data 16 to 49 on your
agenda
um
the strategic performance of ic ict
manager john walker will present
[Laughter]
thank you very much he's moved smith
absolutely
can everybody hear me yeah thank you and
thank you chair um
yes um this item has come from your own
strategic plan
so
councillors will recall that they set
an action with the strategic plan to
investigate the feasibility of becoming
a direct housing provider
so this is our first kind of major
report on that action that members have
um requested and put into their
strategic plan
and as part of this exercise your leader
and your chief executive has the age of
the lga
and subsequently following that
we have discussions with ian
who is from our consultancy
and we have
employed them to to produce this options
report that's in front of you today
um in the report that um i've written
alongside the options report you'll see
some statistics which shows the
kind of issues affecting our residents
the low wages the high high um
[Music]
value properties
um and one of the the
graphs in there shows a very
vividly in that we've had
a five-year
price rise in our properties
in the last couple months
so you know we know it's that we know
it's an issue
we've had some um
workshops with members and bean's going
to go go through that with you in more
detail um in a second um
all of this information that we spoke to
the two workshop remembers we've had
some um sessions with officers the
senior management team
um has come together with a kind of a
program
of the next steps of what we're going to
recommend that we do as an authority to
progress this important issue um so
ian's now just going to explain his
options report how we got there and
he'll
be
available for any questions that members
may have
thank you john and uh good evening
everyone um
uh as as john said in winston from our
consultancy and
obviously i know and have met a number
of you
because we have two very useful sessions
here in in july and i'm acutely aware
that some of you would have been in the
morning some of you would have been in
the afternoon so hopefully this report
starts to bring together all the things
that maybe you didn't hear from the
session that that you were
part of
so the brief was to to look at options
for direct
direct delivery as john said and and we
we
pulled together this report on the basis
of some desktop analysis which john's
team provided
an officer workshop which was a senior
management team workshop which was um in
june and obviously the two workshops
that
you attended
in july what i'm not going to do is go
through the entire report it's quite a
bit of heft in there
and and quite a lot of options what i've
tried to do is is kind of
hone the options into some of the key
things that came out of the of the
workshops so what i would
talk to here is are the drivers that you
highlighted
and some of the priorities that then led
to the recommendations that are in the
report and as john said very happy to
take any questions on the on the wider
narrative
so just on the priorities that came out
of
of all of our our discussions
and what you highlighted was that there
was firstly a lack of breadth of housing
provision
existing housing providers you said are
not always sufficiently focused on on
delivery for torridge and for tourist
families and the mix of homes especially
for younger people weren't always where
you wanted them to be
the pace was also an issue for you in a
scale
and there was some frustration with
commercial developers and also
some other providers that new cool homes
are not being brought forward in the way
that you want
space and space standards and quality
standards uh maybe
you felt that perhaps you didn't have as
much control over as you'd want to
and that the rents that will be in
charge and affordable weren't always
genuinely affordable in the way that you
felt that they should be some social
rent discussion took place some
affordable rent discussion took place
and there is quite a difference between
those two
um there was some stuff around design uh
to do with climate emergency and whether
again the quality of homes that you
wanted to provide were meeting uh that
agenda which you as a council
had signed up to
um and and also there was
this idea that you know
that affordable housing and market
housing both have a place together that
there is sometimes an opportunity for
the council possibly to build market
housing to facilitate some of the
affordable housing
that you want to provide so they they
were the kind of drivers that came out
what we've then done is is we we've
taken those drivers and and looked at
the wider
information that john provided
and and kind of hone those into six key
priorities which we
then take forward and you won't judge
whether these are the priorities but
they're the ones that we
brought out from from that discussion
the first priority is
is that you see the need to provide high
quality genuinely affordable housing and
so there is i think a discussion and a
debate to be had
if you take this forward to a further
phase
to look at what affordable means to you
so i know there has been some debate
around social and affordable rent
and what the what what real
affordability means to to turret
you also said that um or we've drawn out
the deliver the ownership for you as a
council is important
you had disposed of your
stock some years ago
um but delivery is more important than
ownership yes ownership would be great
but actually it's about delivering that
maybe delivery working in partnership
either with an rp registered provider or
housing association with some other clt
community land trust or some other joint
venture partner but also to do things
yourselves if
that's um you're looking for a range of
affordable housing to support all
generations but there was i think the
focus on young people and young families
that are
not being well served by the marketplace
at the moment
but you want to have greater influence
and greater
input into what homes are actually built
on the standards and quality
and that you want to look for strategic
partners that can help you and have a
track record in delivery so they're
they're the key
kind of priorities uh that we drew out
which then um
i was finally
able to make a choice when developing so
that's that rent level stuff the quality
and the zero carbon stuff
and then
what's what what we drew from that is is
some recommendations
which john has already
briefly highlighted there are some quick
wins we think around the viability and
the development management process i
know your plan team are already working
on that kind of stuff but there may be
some opportunities there to to squeeze
more from developers in fairly short
order to deliver affordable homes
through your policies
and positive compliance
you have some lab in ownership and
there's an opportunity to assess that
land
and do some capacity studies on whether
or not
there is the possibility of delivery and
i know that you know land opportunities
have shrunk but there is still some
stuff out there
and then consolidate all that into a
strategic vision for what you want to do
so you know it's very easy with these
things just to say we've got a bit of
land we want to go and develop it
but my experience of working with
councils who are doing this and do this
successfully is that they really start
with what is it we want to do who is it
we want to work with and where do we
want to do it and the pace is there then
much quicker than just jumping straight
in and then having to go back and do
those things
um afterwards
so they're they're the key points that i
drew out i don't really want to
go into more of the 29 page report but
very happy to
respond to any questions on the wider
narrative or all those key points yet
okay for a question
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
can i suggest that there are
ways you can go forward and you've
identified something um
i wonder if we shouldn't be looking at
actually buying houses because um i'm a
member of a local charity there are
other councils here in london uh the
british trust we've just bought five
houses and we got a discount
um
i wonder if we can tie that to planning
commissions that anybody who gets
planning commission
actually has to sell us some housing i'm
not sure where to get the money from
steve but i'm sure it's there
um can i go the one thing that really
struck me was your first bullet point on
page 20 your conclusion
and you mentioned it in your talk to us
and review the process of viability
assessment of planning stay at planning
stage of all major events sites
now
if you look at the figures on you gave
us the figures uh we've built 1200
houses in storage in five years
under our policy we should have got 360
affordable homes we've got 160
and one of the big problems as i said
we
went out to the public and we said have
you got any lands you won't put in the
local plan
the schlaf process
all the land holders came forward and
said yes we've got this
house
what the counselors argued about was
whether we should have that bit or that
bit was always very difficult but nobody
seems to have looked or assessed
the viability of the site and i wonder
if we shouldn't write in write it into
our local plan that any landowner who
puts forward the land they own the
building on has to pay for a viability
study before it's included
in our local plan just so we're not
taken
by surprise
as we were at pitt hill and ecuador and
suddenly
there were no affordable homes because
there was a big problem they
came up with and this happens all the
time develop you can't blame the
developers they do it all the time they
always find issues
and they find expenses
that we weren't aware of i think i
mentioned the one at the torrentine
creamery was a million quid for
marketing which is laughable and
we need to do this we need to look
really closely at that um
so i'm glad i'm glad your reports come
forward but i think we need to be much
more
hard-nosed
in all the ways we look at it and
i was talking to some people who deal
with homelessness just recently
and uh winter is coming winter's here
i wonder if we
we might find ourselves having to look
at bridge buildings put in emergency
accommodation but we'll see if that
happens
the viability assessment i mean my
recollection is that this came out very
strongly when we had the workshop but um
and it was in terms of right at the
beginning of the planning process of
allocation
as it's been stated
so
i would
sort of suggest that we uh that we amend
the first point of recommendations to uh
[Music]
review the process of liability
assessment of the schla station
stage and applications
and the other point i've got is what
query i've got is you know what the time
whether the time scales on these
recommendations
this this is a huge problem
there is reference early on
to there being some concern about the
housing situation
or in my mind it's a huge concern so
you know the sooner we get through
these recommended stages
of
you know what
we're aiming at
you can answer that one first if we wish
date-wise anyway
yeah
we haven't got a firm date um set out
yet because we were waiting for the
obviously the
the goal from full council uh but there
will be project plans and project um
actions for for each of these um ready
to go so the the first one as you said
about the review of the viability
assessment where we're seeing that that
would be linked
to a few meetings of the um local plan
committee and
a review of the planning manager to look
at kind of the process that he's got um
going on at the moment so we're talking
you know i can't put specific dates but
we're talking kind of months instead of
um um years so so we've said every part
of next year we'd be looking at
something to bring forward
um
steve would be um um liaising with the
um
estates manager about assessing all the
land i really i don't know how long that
type of um assessment would take um but
we don't we'd look at all our land um
the funding opportunities i had started
discussions with with the um this
afternoon was whilst i had the
opportunity
so we would start looking at that the
the some of that funding opportunities
um
only come to fruition once you've got a
fully costed program in place so that's
not something um we could do um tomorrow
but at least we would know we can have
those discussions and we would know what
is out there so
um you know we we would start the
actions as soon as as soon as we could
but obviously there are other causes and
um on office of time
thank you councilman
thank you
well first of all the chair i would like
to
propose that we got the recommendation
on page 21
debate
that's the recommendation
sorry because this repeat
secondly the
two previous councils have mentioned
about the first bullet point on that uh
those recommendations about the planning
issue
um
it always amazes me that
you know all the areas in the country
this is gonna be one of the easiest
places to build
well especially on a greenfield site the
geography of this area of devon is such
that you know you've got top soil some
subsoil shell
underneath it's bloody easy to develop
it and yet every time the planning
these developers go to the planet oh i
was
in trouble with the uh the topography of
the uh the site always looking for
excuses there are no excuses and we
haven't been part enough in making them
fulfill what they're supposed to do
so i think that's the point which has
been made before but it needs
emphasizing our planning committee need
to be much tougher
and call them out they say oh we'll go
to appeal because we they know we're not
going to
set up
uh barristers not to defend it but other
authorities have
and we should we should be much tougher
on that one
because we've got uh things like the 106
agreements and the community
infrastructure and every emergency that
mentioned in this report that still
exists or is it gone
the community infrastructure level i see
it nodding there
or
does that mean it still exists so can uh
check
yeah
yeah um
infrastructure
does exist many local authorities apply
it some choose not to um i'm i'm not
sure the other planning position here
sure
we've had a consultant before we said
you can apply
and in fact if you look at the
self-built magazines
where they say about all your costings
your design
legal et cetera et cetera they always
include
at least five thousand pounds of ins in
community infrastructure levels do we
ever do that
not that i could
however
that's dealing with the planning
the other bullet points are fine but i
would like to add another one chair
and that is a last bullet point let's
get this ball rolling great
well let's liaise with other authorities
in this process
an authority that's starting the process
an authority that's in midterm
and authority that's nearly ending
because
let's learn from others this authority
is still
quite
it never used to be
back in the good old days as i like to
call them you know we used to go and
visit other authorities i've been to as
far as edinburgh wakefield
um
because well very sort
as well
listening to their experiences because
if you listen to cancers in particular
they're the ones that are sharp and in
terms of making decisions they actually
will highlight the problems they have
and how they dealt with them we don't do
enough of that i think it was all very
well relying on officers but they really
don't have the time to do all that sort
of stuff but we do on an informal basis
and we should do that because i think
that would help us to smooth out a lot
of the glitches that are going to occur
because there will be a lot of them and
finally i'll go back on my old hobby for
us to sell bill it ain't in this report
either
and yet in the preamble to it it did say
that 80 18
of our uh area are self-employed and i
still we nearly finished our our second
self-built project so i still have a lot
of contacts up in the building um
suppliers and that there's a lot of
young people there who are itching to
get the chance to build their own
because they get that 30
discount by their sweat equity of
building it themselves and we're not
doing that we've had a register of
ourselves built
where where did that go as far as i know
it's just a tick box exercise and we
know some we never received any support
in terms of our self-built project from
this authority not maybe of course it
will vote he will clear him
he's nothing but trouble but never i
understand that but even so
you know you do need some help
give me just one example before i sit
down and shut up
but for example
we had to have solar panels at the very
last minute building control said ah
you're all electric
hang on uh you you will have to have uh
solar powers to improve your um
footprint of appropriate
yeah we were going to do that no you
could have them now before we'll sign
you off
so we had to install them how did that
gas put in as well well we weren't about
to do that how bizarre is that but the
other thing is everybody housing
great
but
suppliers the
utilities people they don't recognize
that you've got to register it you have
got to take the initiative find out
about it and actually register that
you've got solar panels or you don't get
the uh the benefit
of another example of how stupid that is
but that's the way it is but as i said i
would move those recommendations with
that added
bullet point about networking
thank you dr brenton it's been proposed
a second day but before we go to the
vlog
james would like to sum up
thank you i was going to propose it but
um just on some of the points of those
council brenton um last week at the dcn
conference the chief exec and i talked
to
cambridge they're doing something
similar and they're very slightly ahead
of us so we've arranged for their
officer to talk to john walters about
what he's doing this morning i spent two
hours on a zoom meeting with mid devon
and seth hans
mcdevin have got their own hr i'll shake
up how i so they are actually applying
for money to build more houses directly
because they've already got the system
southamptons are planning to do very
similar to us they were looking at
whether they should set up an armstrong
company and how they could actually go
into the system and we're looking at
whether we can build up to
before we have to go into a registered
providing situation so we are doing all
that we're it's a bit slow um
and you know i've been trying to build
affordable homes for 20 years and i'm
still frustrated with it um and self
build we've done a self build scheme
individual 30 years ago
we're trying to do one in holes really
at the moment on wimbledon and the
finances are quite difficult and how you
get that all together um it needs to be
part of another development to actually
do it just as a single
item is quite difficult unless you've
got individual sides
so
um i think we are moving forward and is
a very good report
i think we need to deal with the first
three
on the recommendations and then get on
and get another meeting so we can
actually see what we've achieved where
we're going because it is important i
sometimes look at the figures and wonder
whether it's quite so bad is what we are
being told um but
you know that's not the issue the issue
is that we've got young people who need
hosing and we need to go on and do it
and there are several ways of doing it
um i won't bore you with all the things
we do as a clt
but
as i say we're already talking to other
groups we're already looking at what
they're doing we're already
being mirrored a little bit with what
we're trying to do with myself
and i think we've got a meeting with
andy bates
next tuesday who's the chief recycled um
uh southampton and west evan so we can
raise up then so
i think yes
i'm desperate to get on with it it's too
long to get to this stage just on the
first one the viability that is on the
agenda for the local planned working
group for us to look at how we can start
tackling that
um
the assessment of what we've got and
where we can build is already um been
talked to our safe manager
and the investigating the funding
opportunities that came up this morning
where they're going to come back and
talk to the group folks on the story
about how we can apply for the funding
and it's both
from hosting
so that is up today i think we need to
get something out
that's in the bulletin
about where we are with it all so you
can all actually redo your leisure
okay thank you very much
thank you council james uh coaster
brenton can i ask if you're happy to
accept country james's
summing up or did you still want to add
your additional book
culture uh
from what council james says it sounds
though he he at least is networking with
other authorities and that's that's
[Music]
point to
review the process of liability
assessment
at the
development land allocation stage
bracket
and then continue
[Music]
they will come forward to the local
planned working group and the viability
will then be looked at
when that comes forward so that's
already although it's not actually
printed in there we've already made that
arrangement um so we are going to make
it stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
about the right to buy in my wall
there's a small village of rover that 20
years ago were gifted by government at
the council um 20 acres of land and then
uh this huge farm yard which they built
affordable houses on
um and i contacted them on the right to
buyer
and it says aaron's legacy was a private
registered provider of social housing as
their houses were part funded by the hca
and their tenants do have the right to
acquire after three years tenancy
the discount of the market
value of the house is district dependent
and that president torres discount is
ten thousand pounds
this right to acquire does not apply if
you are in a designated rural area
and the people of rover do not believe
that tolerance is included at present
well why aren't we included in the
designated rural area
there are two ways that tenants can buy
their houses right to buy is one and
that's principally where where local
authorities either are the landlord or
were the landlord and there was a
transfer so your historic tenants can
still go through his run to buy if
they're if they were there originally
right to acquire is an entirely
different scheme and that is applied to
generally housing associations where
those those properties were built by
their housing associations and right to
buy doesn't apply in those cases
there are there are certain
circumstances i don't know specifics but
of this area but there are certain
circumstances where right to acquire
doesn't apply
so for example
in the same way that wright doesn't
write a buy doesn't apply to say some
sheltered homes some supporting housing
homes in your stock or your former stock
um
where um where there is uh a a specific
pressure on affordable housing
uh and certain rural communities may
well be um under pressure then right to
choir doesn't apply in those cases but
that would have been made clear at the
start of the tendency and it would have
been made clear at the point of which
the grant was received from the hca
so um yeah different districts have
different rules but and different
developments have different rules but it
would have been made clear of the outset
why is not registered as a rural area
and that will be a historic
discussion that took place at some point
if that if that's the case i would be
surprised if the whole district wasn't
covered i could see that some some um
specific developments might be excluded
from right to acquire but it's very
unusual for entire districts um to be
excluded if i'm honest
with hicks please
thank you mr chairman can you hear me at
the far end yeah
i'm afraid kenzler hangs his proposal is
totally unworkable
uh there is many a split between twitch
cut and lit
unfortunately
you could do a viability appraisal on
the development today
by the time you come to build it
the government has changed the rules
councillor britain himself pointed out
we end up having that solar
[Music]
you cannot work it out at that stage
it's clowned in the cuckoo land and
unfortunately
with the green lobby running into the
arm now there's going to be an awful lot
more of it
so goodness knows where are you don't go
for that because it ain't gonna work
thank you yes i i don't like to cross
swords or counter the hit or matter like
this but i'm going to it's fine i'm very
counters are hit you're wrong
you've just mentioned oh they changed
you know solar panels if you come to
planning committee you will see that
most of the viability studies where they
say we can't afford affordable homes
it's based on physical factors of the
site they don't change
and i would go back to what i suggested
before if a land owner gets his land put
in our local plan suddenly he's sitting
on the gold mines you know that the
value of his land shoots up without
planning commission
is worth something but not much with
planned parenthood shoots up i cannot
see why that man should not pay for a
viability study before
that land is put into our local plan and
that viability study we'll look at the
physical factors they're the ones that
are always quoted
[Music]
right coachella aims
amendment to that fastball point has
been proposed and seconded
so we need to take a vote on that please
so all in favor
yeah and again please
on abstentions
thank you
okay right whenever you come on to
council brenton's
[Music]
sorry the vote was 20 twenty one again
ten four two abstentions so clearly the
motion slots
um councillor brenton's motion has been
proposed saw his
um
his
recommendation um to approve
uh capturing newton as a second are you
starting to still have a second one as
it's written
yes you're happy that okay
all in favor please show
[Music]
10 on the agenda is uh appointment of an
independent person is for the harvard
board whose phase is 1551
and the operational services manager
is down here
richard
is going to present him
so hopefully this would be a pretty
straightforward one not nearly as
complex as the last issue um
[Music]
uh the biddeford hog or working group
guidance and interaction provided by two
non-elected members those being um
all right
yeah those being mr hard acre and mr
gibbs though their time off has come to
an end and the wifi group would like to
propose that they're re-elected in
addition to that for the last couple of
years mr puddy has been representing
biddeford chamber on the harbour
woodworking group he's been a
non-elected um and non-voting member of
the group and the harper worker would
like to propose that he is elected as a
full voting member
so that just takes us to the
recommendation
that all three members are elected for
general four years okay before we go to
the vault sorry i've got council higgs
first
uh thank you mr chairman the chair of
the harbour board
very strongly recommends
these are three people who understand
the harbor and its work
and they are essentially my opinion to
ensure that it runs out
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
strategic objectives the chief executive
will present this report
on ages 52-54
um thanks chair
um so you've got the the report in front
of you so this is the
start and first report setting out uh
the council's strategic vision for what
you really want to achieve
the provision of leisure services in the
district in the future
following your
recommendation and approval to set up a
local authority trading company back in
july
so you'll recall
some members attended a workshop back in
august
where the the purpose of which was to
start to set out your vision and your
importance objectives what you're on the
trading company active torridge uh
exactly what you want the company to
deliver
um i guess one of the things we have to
remember that establish establishing the
trading company we've now got two
separate entities the district council
and the the trading company active
torridge and we both got different roles
and responsibilities going forward
so really was there's a there's overlaps
in what
we both wish to achieve the company and
the authority
um there's still a significant
relationship between the two
um notwithstanding that activity is a
cons wholly owned council
company
but it also needs to be a distinct
separation between the two
um
excuse me um to that end this initial
document sets out
ten
objectives if we include the additional
one around the carbon reduction net zero
objective that's recently been added in
as part um which came out from the the
discussion leadership so these are the
key things you want the company to
achieve
so the high level
objectives will then enable the council
to start developing these
services specification and that's a more
detailed operational plan if you like
that sets out uh the specific specific
details of what the
the company will deliver much in much in
the same way as a contract between the
council and a contractor would do
and that will set out exactly what's to
be delivered
on a day-to-day basis i guess just for
just for clarity
um activate active tourism as an
independent company will also start to
set out its strategy and start to
consider how it will deal and deliver
the objectives that the council sets out
in its division
um so the the company will also need to
consider the deliverability of the
council's objectives in line with that
services specification and eventually
the the budget uh that torridge uh
assigns to this piece of work
that's the the next phase if you like um
in the process following the setting of
the objectives we're working towards
bringing together a services
specification a business plan and a
financial model will come before full
council at your meeting in december so
that will be that will put together the
the more granular detail around what
active torridge is tasked with doing
um chair i don't intend to go in into
any more detail the objectives are there
as i said they've been derived from
conversations from the workshop from
members i'm happy to answer your
questions
and recommendations on page 54.
thank you for also
coaching
the question yes thank you jeff i think
this all seems um seems very positive
and i i would suppose that we accept the
recommendations and go with this
i think at this point in time we are
dealing here with the sort of broad
brush
objectives of what we want to achieve
and i think that's absolutely fine it's
right nice to set those
at this point and then the specification
will be set
later
i know um
when i when i went to a recent town
council meeting there was there was an
outcry for
um engagement and consultation and i
know i've raised that with the chief
executive previously and the leader as
well i believe
um
i think in order to have a service which
is going to be effective
i think we do need to have
that consultation so that we can
produce a customer
based specification which delivers on
what the community
wants and needs
so i have no doubt that there will be
consultation but tonight can i please
receive the confirmation that that is
going to happen so i can go back to our
our residence and tell them that that is
on the way
yes
there will be consultation and there
won't be
there won't be detailed consultation in
this in these early stages
the key thing is to get the services
that we're running um get things in
place for the first of april and that's
to be something that the the trading
company then can work towards looking at
what what communities uh want
uh capital james could i just second
council jones's
recommendation and so that was a fair
assessment of it counselor jones thank
you
okay no other hands up so it's been
proposed and seconded uh the show of
hands
[Music]
[Music]
you know mr
thank you
55-57
[Music]
that should be this should be relatively
straightforward obviously you've got the
same players the appendix uh so the
recommendation is to approve the program
of committee dates for the next year
thanks
um
the crematorium committee it's a
properly
um set up committee of this council it's
politically balanced and it has the same
standings yeah it doesn't appear
and also clients that the property of
major projects
appears on here because
last week
we had whether on thursday i think it
was a wednesday i had an email saying
there's going to be a meeting tomorrow
um you know some of us do actually do
stuff outside of the council and it was
far too short i know it's been cancelled
now it's been moved but could that be
put on because they are regularly
occurring
um
[Music]
that's well stephen mentioned about
property vote just from something that
our team are going to do a number of
councils are raised with me that you're
used to having the zoom invite in your
calendar so going forward once this has
been confirmed we will send invites out
to all committees that you're on plus
working groups as well so that will then
fill your diary up till the end of 22.
so that should then fill your diary
rather than having to look at this
and then if a meeting moves then you're
a
then i could i fill in my calendar a
year ahead
i have to you know i do talks and stuff
i'd like to have that and also why isn't
the crematorium here
[Music]
um chair so the the crematorium
committee is meeting this friday i
believe and i think
i know the clerk was circulating
potential dates for next year to be
confirmed at the committee so once
they've been confirmed they could be
added to this schedule uh this schedule
is a list of open public meetings which
the major projects working group is a
working group so that's why that's not
shown here there's no reason why we
can't set dates for the years or so that
that can be done uh they can be added to
members diaries this is a schedule of
the
public committee meetings
any other speakers
[Music]
because some members may wish to speak
on items of planning or attend
yeah good idea
[Music]
all in favor please show
thank you
okay look at the page item 13 petitions
there are no petitions
so
um we've
uh first one from country to christie
the second from council of gov so i'll
ask country christian to present his
emotion
um as you can see
there is a five-minute discussion which
is allowed at the discretion
little did i expect when i put this
motion uh down a month ago that um
i'll really be echoing what the prime
minister said at lunchtime uh i didn't
expect that but there we are uh now
you've heard an extremely good speaker
earlier explaining what the syrian bill
was all about and it seems very
suitable to be discussing this during
the same week the fox 26 is happening
cop26 has various targets but two are
very pertinent here
number one is the secure global net zero
emissions obviously and the second is to
protect natural habitats
now the ce bill as you heard from the
public speaker earlier is designed to
actually
develop a binding strategy on the
government
i could be rude about the prime minister
and say you know he says all sorts of
things and nothing much happens but
we do need a structure in place a
binding strategy for this
um
and i think that's what this bill is all
about now the bill has attracted the
support of 118 mps and parliament
already
uh here in devon
it has been supported by devon county
council
it's also been supported by north devon
council by mid devon district council
it's also been supported by biddeford
town council northern town council
basketball town council torrington town
council ilfraku town council and linton
town council and there are parishes as
well have voted on this
torridge didn't support it last time i
hope you all support it this time now
there are six issues
identified on my motion uh i'll just go
through very quickly the first one
well torridge has already declared a
climate emergency
uh the second one
we do need to look at emissions right
away from the extraction of raw
materials through to disposal
thirdly it's very important we treat all
aspects of our economy in the same way
we don't let some off the hook
uh fourthly
this one is talking about overseas
because at the moment we get things like
you buy your food i don't know how many
of you look at the ingredients palm oil
since so much of our food
and we take it for granted and yet you
look at the
economic and ecological destruction
of the production of palm oil elsewhere
in the world and we need to look at that
uh the
uh fourth one there
um
[Music]
i'm sorry fifth one i should say the
fifth one um about the source i'll give
you an analogy it says oh we've been
emptying the supermarket shells for the
last 200 years
now is the time to start restocking and
if you look at the agricultural payment
system
it's going to be very heavily focused on
exactly this
and the last point um this i know this
upset a few people last time this idea
of a citizen's assembly
it's already been done in devon and who
did it devon county council a
conservative control council who had no
problems with it and actually we've all
had that report i don't know how many of
you have read it on the climate they had
a citizens assembly on that and it
worked
so i don't think we should vote against
it now there is public support for this
there's a lot of public support and we
only had to look at what happened a
couple of weeks ago in parliament
they voted down an amendment about
dumping sewage into our rivers and
coastal waters a huge public outcry
about it and their back track
that is the public expressing its views
i won't go into all i can quote loads of
figures about um
opinion polls and so on but we know
there is a demand for action out there
so i hope you will
support this
bill tonight and i will ask for a
recorded vote
speakers if not i'll take it again it's
been proposed councillor brent and every
seconder
all those in favor
i did ask for a recorded vote
well you're going to put your hands up
first are you going to call them okay
well
chrisley had the opportunity to discuss
it i did ask if there were any speakers
if you wish to speak president
just a slight balance i noticed that
west edmond borough council did not fit
for it in fact they went against it um
there are some major issues here which
are actually
being considered and have been looked at
very carefully by government and whether
we here should be trying to dictate
whether this country
is responsible for
picking up the what will become
a liability
for international
uh damage repair
um
is a a major major discussion area and i
would question whether we had a flick of
a switch we should be um throwing our
weight behind that
uh also i cannot despite what other
people may say i cannot support
the concept
that
which is really that the citizens
assembly through
a growing
noise
will hijack and take control
of the decision-making of our elected
government of the day and it doesn't
matter what color that government is it
is a principle that is our democratic
process
they are our democratic um
representatives and
they need to be allowed to get on of
course people make their point and they
lobby etc but this despite the fact that
last minute weasel words oh well we
don't really mean it that you know they
only have to take note of it well the
intent is actually to to try to take
control i have no doubt and as a result
in these terms uh mr chair i'm afraid i
will not be able to support uh this
major solution okay
i just want to say that i think we all
in every way we can need to take
responsibility and do anything we can
which means voting for this thank you
[Music]
anyone else wish to speak
religious sure
yes sir
i mean
okay
we may be we may have this burden
but come on
um the western governments and then we
we included
are the ones that have done this damage
in the past
so i think it is up to us to do
something with them
and you know if that means
uh this council
um
brought before that i should be moving
for this
i think it is our responsibility
to
um
you know join with other councils
to uh you know put our point forward
that's another one you know i didn't
vote for this last time i i can't
support you this time either there's two
things particularly that i objected in
there's a lot more actually in this than
this is shown here
but this protects and restores
biodiverse habitats
along overseas supply chains i don't
expect that this country should be
responsible and be able to do that
and the final one is this
citizen's assembly
which if you looked and haven't been
online last time i looked
at the mps in the main who've signed up
to this
they're nearly all left winners or
scottish nationalists
and fellow travelers with them
extinction rebellion and all that all
those they're all involved
i'm sorry but i can't support
[Music]
his uh his response from that as well
i mean
surely you must realize what is
happening in anything you could do to
improve the situation
do you remember the ozone player that
was actually caused a lot by the
advanced countries of the world chucking
that gas into the atmosphere and that
was banned and the ozone layer did
actually get restored restore itself
small beer compared to what's happening
now absolutely it is i mean if you want
to continue with this sort of weather
pattern that we've got at the moment oh
good luck to you but i sure as hell
don't want to i think everything we can
do within our power we should do it
thank you
there is much good here and there's some
bad items it's a bit like the curax
so if we don't agree with everything on
it we can't support it
thank you right it's been proposing
second hit but before we can actually
take it to a recorded vault we have to
have five members support a
recorded vote so
one two three four
yeah
okay so it's a recorded phone call
okay you've heard mr christie's
notice of
so can i have a show of hands for all of
them
oh sorry yeah
i would never record it call it at the
top
cancel the boat again
councillor branson four
councillors
[Music]
again
councillor hudson paul
councillor hurley engaged councilman
[Music]
councillor inch four
councillor james fall
councillor jones against council of
langford council of laws four
councillor leather against
council
against councillor manly
council mcgowan
four
council mackenzie
councillor newton and games council
pennington
councillor watson again
councillor wiseman again
[Music]
16 against
[Music]
okay that brings us on to counterfeit
gov's notice of motion
just go to the microphone
you can if you wish to or you can
thank you
um
do i need a second at first before i go
onto this or no
thank you
i would like to ask my fellow counselors
to stand with me in my motion this
evening i believe that people with mnd
should receive a rapid response to their
needs good care and support ensuring the
highest quality of life as possible
and the ability to die with dignity
let us join other councils throughout
the country and adopt the multineural
disease chapter
i would also like to i presume this has
got to go to cnr i've been advised that
this should go to cnr
and so i would like to
amend my motion
with that and add also
that
i don't think it should just be for
motor neural disease it should be
um with everyone for everyone with life
limited conditions that that should be
looked into as well
to see how we deal with these things
within the council thank you
thank you job
more second advice
[Music]
is
[Music]
did you have your
all in favor first of all
sorry
sorry there's a point of order
the government on men's
motion do we not have to have a vote on
that amendment just to be clear what we
are actually voting
that's quite a bit does a council of
golf
[Music]
catch your eye
[Music]
cough has just
so
specific to major neuron disease has
been removed entirely from the it's
multi-neural disease that's specific to
that has been removed and it widens up
to other
illnesses that got you know
life-threatening
outcomes
are correct
kosher haines
[Music]
yes
but then she then added that
it should also include all other
life-threatening illnesses
for life
[Music]
is that all right
life-limiting
[Music]
um
i
you would you would have may have seen
my letter that i circulated yes where i
wrote to mr lev um and i had a very good
conversation back with him
and um i stressed to him and he accepted
me he was disappointed but i stressed to
him that
the
the items here in the mnd charter i have
absolutely no issue with at all and
those are
a level of quality of care that should
be given to anybody with a terminal
illness we don't doubt that at all
however um
but where it went on
to
in effect instruct
staff and people within the council that
they had to um put emphasis on that i
couldn't accept that because as i as you
saw in my letter that we are putting it
ahead of or
separate from other terminal illnesses
and surely they all uh are the same
i find that in fact we're we're still
keeping with the mnd charter and then
adding a little bit on the end to try to
make it now acceptable by saying and
anybody else as well
i'm afraid it's still as a result to me
putting too much emphasis on one
particular illness ahead of other
equally
catastrophic
terminal illnesses where people deserve
exactly the same level of care
and consideration
and consideration within the employment
place and everything else um but what
to me it seems wrong
still that we're putting
one disease and how we
are meant to be treating people with it
and affected with it
different to another disease of a
similar level of a terminal level or
whatever um so i'm i res i'm still
unhappy uh
the i know councillor gov attempted to
settle this by saying and anybody else
but i think that's been thrown in really
as an afterthought surely yes we go
thank you
i would like to make my motion
again
that
all people with life limited conditions
with that's all of us yeah um
can this please go to cnr so that all
people like limiting conditions
i i just would like to be interested to
see
what happens within the council how we
deal with these people who have these
life-limited
[Music]
whether it can be amended
[Music]
[Music]
um
is
okay if i could have your attention
again please
it would appear
[Music]
what they basically do is they change
your nose emotion
um too substantially so you'd rather
have to we either have to vote on the
motion as it is
presented
or otherwise you withdraw the notice of
motion and then revisit it at a later
date
so um
[Music]
thank you very much
okay i'm from 15 and 16.
part two items so
thank you very much